raising the Ukrainian flag once more
soldiers filmed themselves as they took
the turn of Kali nivska in the kharsan
region and they continued to make
advances taking towns and Villages as
they make their way to the regional
Capital Hassan but they are proceeding
with caution
the Hostile is continue in the hersan
regions and behind every so-called
Goodwill gesture of the anime there are
tremendous efforts from our forces so
the possible exit from the hersom is a
result of all active resistance
What's Left Behind the Russian military
vehicles and destroyed Bridges just
weeks ago Russia was telling residents
that her son would be a part of Russia
forever now they're leaving and the
ukrainians are on the March
Muslims are with us Christians are with
us everyone is with us the whole world
is with us
but this is what's left behind we're
just kilometers away from the front line
and this town has seen a lot of damage
every building has some sort of shrapnel
damage bullet holes or completely
destroyed
there's no electricity there's no water
and the time that we've spent here we've
hardly seen any residents
during the occupation I sent info to our
military I also stole the Russian
document because I knew that in the
future they could be useful to our
prosecutor's office the police now our
Ukrainian military all the locals help
each other I help people from other
villages in town to get safety to the
territories controlled by our Ukrainian
Army so that no one would catch him
we met stanislav who is repairing his
grandmother's house
the shell hits the corner of the house
and the wall collapsed so now we are
building probably a new house when it
was no longer possible to Bear my family
and I left people helped us to get out
through the secret roads it's going to
be a real struggle to rebuild this
damage and destruction like this across
her son but also the Ukrainian forces
that we've spoken to are not completely
convinced that the Russians will
withdraw because of the hard-fought
battles in Kansas Villages across this
region but even if Russian forces would
throw to the east side of the river
her son and the rest of the country is
well within Striking Distance for the
Russian forces but for now the empty
buildings here
are occupied just by the birds
let's bring in Assad bagh now who's in
Creve Assad different narratives
obviously coming from kievan Moscow
how's that playing out on the ground
whether absolutely throughout this award
there's been claims and character claims
information and misinformation but
currently what the ukrainians are saying
is that the Russian troops were throwing
a damaging infrastructure or destroying
infrastructure in her son they're
accusing them of blowing up sewers and
and as well as a television center now
the defense minister Alexia reznikov now
he said that there's still 40 000
Russian troops that remain in the Hassan
region and he believes it will take at
least a week for the the Russian troops
to withdraw from the capital of the
Hassan region which is her son now the
operational command here in the South
have said that they continue to make
gains they've been talking about how
many kilometers they've taken how many
villages and towns that they've taken uh
and they said but they say that the
situation is still tense with the
Russians moving across to the east side
of the river taking up defensive
positions and shelling uh Ukrainian
positions now the Ukrainian is also
saying that they've destroyed a number
of Russian equipment supply lines
Logistics helicopters but you spoke
about about that competing narrative now
the ukrainians have really been strict
with the media and foreign journalists
in comparison to the start of the Year
we're restricted in terms of where we
can go what we can report on and certain
places we can't report from for example
um and although the ukrainians are happy
to make claims about how many Russian
soldiers they've killed or how many how
much equipment they've destroyed but
when the Russians make counter claims
they're not confirm or deny and the
ukrainians never tell us how many troops
they've lost but the Russians although
they're withdrawing to the other sides
of the river can still strike places in
Ukraine an example of that is in the
port city of mikalayev they hit a
residential building and the latest
information we have about that is that
four people have died
all right thank you so much for bringing
us up to speed Assad Bay get live for us
in Korea thank you